[Music]
hey i'm courtney coop i am the head of
great big story all month long we've
been celebrating our great big planet
and telling stories about the incredible
people who are on a mission to protect
and preserve our planet so today i'm
really excited to be able to have a
conversation with two of those people
and really dig into what it is that they
do and what are ways that we all can
kind of help give back to our great big
planet so
joining me uh wes larson you are no
stranger to great big story you have
been joining us all week long as our
ambassador for great big planet and you
are our host of the series mission wild
yeah and for those of you that don't
know wes
he is a wildlife conservationist and
more specifically a bear biologist
which is the coolest job title in the
whole entire world
uh and lauren singer it's so nice to
have you uh you have really for me
put a face and a human connection to the
zero waste movement i think your most
famous probably for being able to fit
every single piece of garbage you've
created over the past four years uh six
is it six years seven years okay i can
count sorry i should have just said
seven that's been a lot nicer for the
past seven years which is even more
mind-boggling uh into that mason jar
that is sitting near you but that's
really just the start uh you do so much
more for zero waste you are the ceo of
package free
which is a shop in brooklyn and then you
also have a site called trash is for
tossers
so we call
this conversation why i'm in it
so let's kind of take it all the way
back to the very beginning for both of
you
how did you first discover your love for
the environment
i'm super curious about bearbite okay so
yeah i grew up in montana which was kind
of a
like a perfect place for a budding
naturalist i guess um
so yeah i you know i was just always
really fascinated with anything
wild anything that
especially anything that could hurt me
uh like the the dangerous animals were
always the ones that were really
fascinating to me and i was lucky to
have parents that
really cultivated that in me they saw
that it was kind of the thing that i was
most passionate about
we'd go on lots of road trips and i'd
always just like sit with my face
pressed up against the glass like
pointing out every single animal i saw
and like trying to identify it usually
getting it wrong but still just being
like really excited so yeah i think that
was mostly it just uh growing up in a
place that kind of nurtured that and
then also having family that
saw how important it was to me and like
you know checking out books for me this
was before the internet so it's like
we'd go to the library and check out
every single book and then we you know
my mom let me watch discovery channel
every night and it was just kind of
this perfect storm of things that all
came together that that made me really
fascinated in the natural world how
about you lawn
um
i didn't grow up
with like a family that talked about
sustainability or environmentalism but i
did grow up in a place where i was
always playing outside so i think i
always had a connection to nature
but my senior year of high school i read
rachel carson's book silent spring
which she was really the woman that like
launched the environmental movement in
the 1960s
and
it was my first realization that
people
human beings are the only creatures on
planet earth that can
do things that can mess up the world for
every other thing that lives here and it
gave me this sense of one fear but two
like
huge amounts of power
that like realizing that i have the
power as an individual to make choices
that could either be positive or like
incredibly negative for everyone that's
a very powerful thing um
and then i went into college and started
i actually went to college for
journalism um but i i promptly failed um
i just like hated everything about them
uh was in environmental science because
i had to take a science class and
realize that i was just like front and
center
every day was obsessed with talking
about it was obsessed with learning
about it and kind of like you like it
was just the thing that i it like came
from my gut it came from like my my
heart everything i thought about was
like pertaining to something around the
environment and um i think
that led into a million different paths
that brought me to where i am now but it
was really just learning about the power
of people to impact the world in a
positive or negative way and and taking
responsibility for that and then
doing all the things that i did after i
think what's really interesting is you
both talk about the impact at a young
age whether that you were really young
or as a teenager and it just goes to
show that the things that you learn at
that time you're impressionable and it
does stay with you
and for you both you took that passion
and actually turned it into your
profession um
when did you kind of decide to make that
decision yeah it was it was like a long
it was a long road for me but uh
when i was like when i was pretty young
still uh there's this pond right next to
where we grew up and i'd go down there
and i'd like catch frogs and turtles and
snakes and uh i'd take them home for a
few days and like i had this tank and
i'd like sit there and watch them and
every once in a while i want to get lost
in the house and that's a whole
different story that um that my mom
could talk about for hours but uh
then you know i'd go release them and it
was this big kind of tradition for me
it's what i did all summer
and there's a certain species of frog it
was a leopard frog that like was kind of
the frog that i would always catch
and there was just like tons of them at
this pond and by the time i was 10 they
were completely gone there wasn't a
single one left and uh
i think that was like kind of like a gut
check for me as like a kid like
realizing that things are finite and
that you know that we can really affect
things and i talked to some people um in
the community and they talked about you
know the ozone layer and how frogs are
really uh susceptible to changes in
environment and there's like a certain
type of fungus that that comes in and
wipes them out and so it like
this thing that i cared about this thing
that like was a big part of my life like
it feels weird to say that a frog was a
big part of my life but it was
uh was suddenly like ripped away from me
and that's
probably when i first kind of realized
what conservation meant and that like
that it was even something that we
needed um
and from there i kind of you know i went
to college and and kind of went down
this track whereas like i need to make
more money i need to do something that's
practical that you know will help me to
raise a family and then
um so i went down an optometry route and
hated it and just kind of every single
day felt like i was losing a little bit
of my soul
and
and then i so i quit and i went and met
with a professor who
worked with bears and they'd always been
of special interest to me
and i went and bugged him every day for
like a year night or not every day every
week for probably like a year and a half
until he finally gave me a job and since
then it's yeah it's been kind of my
whole life so we're we're really lucky
that you guys didn't become journalists
yeah or
interesting
yeah i'd be i'd be pretty miserable if i
was an optometrist right now but for all
those optometrists out there it's great
what you're doing thank you because i'm
very blind
we appreciate optometrists uh lauren i'm
i'm fascinated by just the concept of
zero waste and i'm sure
the people come up to you constantly and
are just insanely curious about it but
it's because it's a really big idea and
it's a really hard thing to wrap your
brain around so explain to me kind of
how you see zero waste what does it mean
for you what does your day-to-day look
like so
zero waste seems really scary from a
zoomed out perspective because it's like
when people think about it they're
taking
themselves where they are now and trying
to impose like nothingness on it which
is very weird to be like okay i have all
this stuff and make all the trash and
then like tomorrow i'll have none
and that's confusing and seems
overwhelming and impossible but like
that's not how it works
zero waste for me started first with
reducing the amount of plastic that i
was using that's kind of how i got into
zero waste it was because i was
protesting against the oil and gas
industry and really passionate about
anti-hydro fracking and realized through
a series of events that i was a huge
hypocrite that i was using plastic
multiple times per day multiple touch
points per day from the food that i was
eating and buying to my beauty products
that were packaged in plastic my
cleaning products my clothing which was
predominantly petrochemical based
fabrics i was participating in fast
fashion which is why it's it's so often
so cheap um
there was a huge misalignment between
the way that i was living my life and
the things that i was incredibly
passionate about and so
that's when i realized i had to make a
change and and that change was first
reducing the amount of plastic that i
was using and then um that turned into
realizing that i couldn't buy my way out
of using plastic you can't walk into a
pharmacy and buy your daily routine
without plastic um so i had to start
making a lot of my own products so i
started with toothpaste and then went
into body lotion and deodorant and
cleaning products and through that i
learned about the concept of zero waste
and it was to me like the most amazing
the most empowering the coolest thing
that i had ever heard because up until
that point i was like yelling at every
building lobbying every politician
organizing every rally trying to like
scream at the world and be like change
and
that's so ineffective i mean it's
important but not incredibly effective
especially when i was also contributing
to the problem that i was fighting
against so zero waste was my way to take
responsibility for my personal impact on
the planet and live my day-to-day life
in alignment with my values for
environmental sustainability
and at first
people didn't know what i was doing or
that i was doing anything different
because my style stayed the same my
routine stayed the same it was just i
was making i was making different
choices but at the time this was seven
years ago
people didn't bring mason jars to fill
up their coffee and they didn't you know
like really compost and still not really
and so i'd start to get questions and
that's why i started trashes for tossers
because
when you start talking about trash and
like personal impact people can get
really defensive um because it feels
like you're challenging and criticizing
the way that somebody is living now
which isn't the case at all like we're
all where we're at um and with
information maybe we can make steps to
reduce our waste and so
um trashes for tossers was like a really
safe place for people to learn about
what i was doing in a way that felt like
non-threatening and non-confrontational
and non-judgmental
and then that kind of just grew but i
think
living your values and like being an
embodiment and like a version of
confidence around an issue is a much
more
effective way at trying at making change
and wes conservation is also
a really big
complicated issue to wrap your brain
around
so when it comes to you
what does conservation mean to you and
how does it affect your day to day
yeah uh it is it's it's like i think
you know in today's world where people
really like to just kind of get surface
of like a million different topics
instead of kind of really diving into
things
conservation's become you know somewhat
of a buzzword where it's kind of like
something that's thrown out but it's
very vague and people often don't really
understand the time and effort that goes
in towards like into actual
wildlife conservation so for me um
it's kind of you know it's this long
process it's
it's rooted in tradition there's this
whole process of like
you know you go out you have a question
in mind a hypothesis that you need to
answer you go out and you study whatever
species you might be studying you try to
answer that question and then you
publish a paper and that paper goes into
scientific literature and that's kind of
like the standard for conservation
but i do think you know with the
changing world and a changing kind of
media landscape um
you know you kind of have to enter into
this new era of outreach and kind of
teaching people
about the issues and letting people get
involved in those issues so there's new
things that are kind of coming up like
citizen science projects where people
can actually get involved in their
hometown or their home area in wildlife
conservation they can help researchers
kind of gather that data that they need
so it's it's like that's a big question
it's one that's hard to answer kind of
in a short blurb but there's there's a
lot of different ways that conservation
is being carried out in a modern world
and one of them is just really education
just teaching people
what those issues are and how they
personally can help you know with
whatever animal might be imperiled
i
think what you do
is both the coolest and the most
dangerous and crazy thing i've ever ever
heard because i mean it's true you are
on
what is essentially the front lines
getting face to face with bears yeah uh
in the name of studying them so that we
can understand how to protect them yeah
but that means that you've put yourself
in some crazy situations yeah a couple
tell me more about that uh like the one
the one that comes to mind and uh it's
one that i talk about a lot because
there was actually a
national geographic photographer with us
when we went on this trip but um
with i've i did a project where we'd
actually call our black bears we put a
gps collar on them and we're learning
kind of what habitats they're using
and trying to help them avoid
campers around bryce canyon national
park and
so this coloring process involved like
catching a bear in a trap putting a
collar on it and letting it go but then
in the winter we'll actually go into
their dens and while they're asleep and
kind of check to make sure that collar
is not too tight
and they wake up like they hear is
coming they wake up
they can pop out of their hibernation
pretty quickly and so it's pretty like
that can be kind of a scary thing how
big are bears how many pounds yeah so
these are black bears
our black bears were anywhere from like
100 pounds to like 400 pounds um
so
typically these dens are made kind of in
like a shallow crevice in the rock and
you can go up and i have a i have a pole
that has a syringe on it and i just kind
of poke the bear from outside with some
ketamine and let the bear fall asleep
and then i can pull it out and do
whatever i need to do but this
particular day that we went with this
photographer we found this den and it
was actually like 80 feet long and it
was this narrow tube and black yeah and
it's yeah pitch black as soon as i poke
down with my headlamp i see these two
green eyes staring back at me from the
back of the den and it's my biggest bear
it was like a 400 pound male and the
males are a lot trickier to work with in
the dens because they often they don't
have cubs so they're like prone to kind
of just bust out and leave
so i had to crawl on this den and i'm
like just inching towards this bear was
just big enough for me my little
brother's behind me and he's just like
don't do this don't do this don't do
this he was kind of my helper and i
finally had to be like shut up like i
need to we need to get the spare it's
cholera's getting really tight so we
wanted to make sure that it didn't
tighten up too much on it um and so we
kept going and the bear like and me kind
of had this little
stand off we have a yeah we have a photo
of it here uh we had this little
standoff kind of an egg
in the end of the end of the den and uh
and i just kind of sat there and watched
this behavior
and so when they're like when they're
aggressive
the bear will kind of do like a
noise and it will shake its head and it
will clack its jaws and then they'll
actually charge at you and kind of like
um let you know that it's like okay i'm
a bear you're not supposed to be in here
with me like you know you're doing what
you're not supposed to be doing uh but
it didn't and it it actually let me pull
out my syringe and sedate it um
which luckily like you know went pretty
well and it was a really scary night it
was like it was terrifying it's one of
those things where it's like
you wouldn't want to crawl in this this
hole in the ground
even knowing that there's like nothing
there so like knowing that there's a 400
pound predator at the end of it like the
one thing you don't want to be in there
like i really had to suppress some like
primal kind of instincts of like get the
hell out of here like you shouldn't
be in here so yeah that was a really
scary one yeah so
so we call this conversation why i'm in
it yeah and i'm listening to you both
talk about what you do on a day-to-day
basis and you put yourself in harm's way
and you make pretty big sacrifices and
you dedicate a lot of time and neither
one of you what you're doing it isn't
easy
so why do you do it
do you want me to go first sure okay uh
yeah for me
uh
kind of like what lauren was saying
earlier like
realizing that we're not alone on the
planet and realizing that we do have
the intelligence and the power to affect
everything else out there um and and for
the most part we've been doing it
negatively uh it it makes me feel this
like really intense responsibility to
kind of give these animals a voice
to uh to kind of yeah to let people know
how we're affecting them um i think
people you know you see these programs
in these documentaries where you see
these wild places and it seems like
everything kind of on the surface is
okay
you know where it's like oh like they
have all this space and all these places
where animals are thriving
and and a lot of people don't know the
truth and don't know that like literally
every single species on this planet is
being impacted by us
and uh and they don't have a way to kind
of convey that to us they can't tell us
you know like hey guys like
he's like ease off all the plastic like
stop you know stop ruining everything
and
and so like me kind of being able to
start
having that knowledge like i'm very new
in my field being able to kind of learn
that firsthand
it makes me feel this kind of intense
responsibility to spread that awareness
how about elon
i think for me it's
my
i mean i have won one goal in life and
it's to help to create large-scale
positive environmental change that's
been my north star since i was a
freshman in college um
and
everything that i do is about that so i
never know where that's going to take me
but
but for like i mean people that are in
the sustainability field are very much
in it for very aligned reasons um
i
want to take responsibility for the
impact that my species has on all the
other species and
help to share that message with other
people and ultimately
like maintain this like perfection that
is the planet but i think also it's less
for
the planet sometimes and more for
humanity because if humans
if we
went extinct the planet would be fine i
i like to say that nature always
prevails and um if we were gone things
would like snap back pretty quickly it
would look a little different but it
wouldn't um
nature wouldn't miss us so much um so i
think humans are are really interesting
and amazing and i'd like to preserve our
species and i think just making people
aware that like
you have the power to to eradicate your
own species um is an important message
and
i guess like one preserving the planet
but to yeah just
keeping people around um and helping
them to live in a way that's a lot in
alignment with like this natural balance
of earth and um so they can keep
creating and innovating and doing all
the amazing things that people do
without [ __ ] it up for everyone else
would you say
part of the curiosity around zero waste
is people can't myself included can't
wrap their their brain around
the lives that they are currently living
today
and that's been something knowing i was
going to talk to you guys that i've been
thinking about for myself a ton which is
i'm
stubborn i'm stuck in my ways i have
routine i have habits and there seems to
be this mountain between the
acknowledgement and recognizing
everything that's wrong but actually
really doing something about it like
that that difference between knowing and
doing
is quite big so when people ask me what
the hardest thing about like
living this lifestyle is i would say
it's that exactly it's not the actual
process of reducing your waste because
it's just a lot of really tiny easy
changes that add up over time but it's
the
the mental block the preconceived
narratives in overcoming them to just
start yeah that tends to be really
difficult for people um like there's
this preconception that sustainability
is hard or elitist or expensive um
those things can be true or not true um
but i've started living this lifestyle
when i was a senior in college on a
senior in college college budget
and
executed it
to a way where it worked for me saved me
money i was eating healthier my life
completely improved i found that i had
more time so it's overcoming those
narratives and um just just starting
just doing like one little thing whether
it's saying no to plastic straws or
saying no to plastic bags or doing
something like composting or even just
taking the time to think about what your
waste is looking in your garbage can
looking at what you're throwing away and
just like step one is really taking
responsibility it's almost like
in aaa it's like you have to recognize
that you have a problem and only then
can you start making um
change and and make change that's
actually like sustainable long-term um
so
yeah that really is the hardest thing
it's just like i recognize that the way
that i'm living isn't perfect and i
commit to doing something about it even
if i'm not perfect even if it's not like
completely zero waste i'm committed to
trying to make a more positive impact
whatever shape that takes well and so i
wanna you don't have to dump it out but
i wanna kind of just point out your
mason jar because you obviously are
trying very very hard to eliminate waste
from your life
but but it goes to show that there's
even
garbage that you can avoid
so
when you look through this what are the
things that you notice most often in
there well because this is seven years
old and when i really started doing this
sustainability wasn't really in the
narrative like
of
popular culture my my two choices when i
graduated from college for a career were
like government and non-profit and there
was no such thing as like sustainable
cpg or like i don't know if there were
no jobs in sustainability that were like
cool or sexy or whatever um and so a lot
of these things that are in here now
have solutions because
starting companies to solve problems has
become much more prevalent
mission-driven companies are much more
prevalent so the things that are in here
are it's all plastic 100 plastic
and it's things that are not
recyclable in municipal recycling so
there are solutions like i could take
this and give it all to um this company
called terracycle whose motto is recycle
everything and um this could all be
turned into something else or recycled
but i hold on to it as just
a bit of information about what isn't
conventionally municipally recyclable
and the things that are created that are
just stuff that doesn't necessarily need
to exist so it's like festival bracelets
that's a huge one if you've ever gone to
a music festival they give you those
like little bracelets and now they have
like microchips in them which is like
even more extra um
there's plastic wrap
like saran wrap in there
there's band-aids but now we sell
biodegradable bandages at package free
there's some gaffers tape for all you
film people out there um
and then the things that connect a price
tag of clothing to the piece of clothing
whoever invented those
like probably so rich right now um
but they're just so
archaic um there has to be a better way
to like put the price of an item on that
item without needing two pieces of
material um
uh and then produ stickers again like a
kind of archaic thing with all the
technology that we have now um so so
yeah i would say that's the predominance
of it thin thin plastics um
and just like the inner tags of clothing
so even if a piece of clothing is like
totally natural like 100 cotton a lot of
the times the wash labels are on
synthetic so they won't fade
through washing so it's just these
little tiny problems that you wouldn't
think about when you think of like the
giant trash problems but even though
they're small they're they're still
problems
i am you've motivated me to go through
my own trash and just think about it and
for for me it's paper towels
uh and coffee grinds the two things but
i also am very fortunate that i live in
a neighborhood where i can compost so
i've kind of started doing that this
weekend towels are such a good choice
that was like one of the first ones that
my boyfriend started doing he just
started reducing his waist and um it's
had like such a big impact because one
it just looks a lot nicer than having
this like
tall
phallic looking thing on your countertop
that's like just goes in the trash and
two it's cheaper and they just clean
really well and you wash them so it's
like a really easy swap and um i think
it's a lot cuter yeah i mean what are
you thinking about
one person can make a difference one
person can can change something about
what they do and how they live their
lives what is your recommendation yeah
uh
i mean something i think about a lot is
uh
uh over overfishing so this is like uh
like a very conservation related issue
but one that doesn't get nearly as much
kind of
air time i guess is you know climate
change and a few and they're all
interconnected but um overfishing is one
that really scares me and it's a problem
that
is like massive in scale and we're
destroying you know a huge percentage of
our planet the ecosystems there
by eating way too much fish and so
something i stopped doing a long time
ago was just i just stopped eating
seafood
there are definitely sustainable options
there's places where you can get
fish that was caught sustainably
but i kind of hated being the person at
the restaurant that was like hey where'd
you catch this how was it caught where
was it caught and so i just decided to
completely stop eating it and um i think
people don't realize that like you know
if you ordered if you go to a sushi
restaurant and you order bluefin tuna
you might as well be ordering like
orangutan or or white rhino or something
like you're yeah you're essentially
eating that same animal that's how
endangered they are and that's you know
and no one talks about it yeah and uh
and it's such a huge industry i mean
like one bluefin tuna in you know some
of those like japanese fish markets will
go for hundreds of thousands of dollars
and so it's this huge industry with a
ton of money behind it um
and because it's a fish because it's
this animal that we don't really
have a connection to that we don't
really like see ourselves in
people don't really talk about it i mean
there's like 100 like over 100 million
sharks every year sometimes are killed
by you know shark fitting that's like
the upper end of the estimate but it's
not you know it's not something that we
can continue to do and still have a
functioning ecosystem and so
that's one of those things that i think
people can kind of take personal
responsibility for and if you do i mean
if you're a sushi fan great if you love
seafood that's fine but you need to do
it ethically you need to ask those
questions can you talk about like the
like the top three no's and the top
three yeses like if you are gonna eat
yeah my my top couple knows would be
sharks like i would never touch anything
that has shark in it they're like yeah
they're an insanely important predator
in the ecosystem um
and they're they're beautiful animals
like and they don't have the advantage
of being like a dolphin or a whale or
something that we just naturally care
about people are scared of sharks so we
don't really care that they're being
killed so sharks um bluefin tuna
and
uh i'm drawing a blank on a third one
for you i'm just gonna do two for now
yeah shrimp's a big one too honestly
anything that's farm too in the ocean uh
the fish farms are
incredibly destructive so i would say
yeah i would say sharks bluefin and then
farm
ocean farming
and then what was your other question
sorry some some like okay ones
wanting some ocean food so the ones that
i usually look for are kind of the
aquaculture
inland um so like tilapia farms are
often pretty sustainable
um alaska has really good fisheries that
are well regulated and have good quotas
so typically if you caught if you have
wild caught
alaskan salmon or whatever you're pretty
safe
but there's apps out there there's
things that you can look at that you can
take to the restaurant um and it'll tell
if that restaurant serves sustainable
fish it'll tell what kinds of fish you
can order um
but it seems like a pain but it's it's
one of those things that like i've had
sleepless nights thinking about what
we're doing to our oceans and and we're
going to notice the effects of it in our
lifetime this isn't something that it's
like oh my kids kids will worry about
that totally this is for us so this is
like 12 years this is like this is like
i'm gonna be like i won't even be 40. i
mean some like some fisheries scientists
you know say that within 50 years we
might we will lose all of our major fish
stocks like so there's there's
and then on top of that it's a human
issue too because there are whole
cultures that depend on those fish and
they can't catch the fish that they need
anymore for their you know just for
their
their daily kind of like nutrition
because we have these huge fleets of
commercial vessels that are kind of just
taking everything and so it's a huge
problem it's one that i think
people can take personal accountability
for just in their decisions they make
with their diet
so we at great big story like to say
ripples make waves
and so we can all be a ripple we can all
change one thing um i don't want to end
on a super downer of a note even though
this can be a downer of a conversation
but
we like to tell stories that give people
hope about the world that they live in
so where are you both seeing hope right
now
for me like
and there's a really big bug on the
floor
hi bud
happy earth month
on it um yeah it's cute um
kind of
in so many places and that's one of the
reasons i started living a zero-waste
lifestyle was to take responsibility and
realize that like
i'm not gonna be depressed by the world
around me or like i i can't be allowed
to be depressed about the world around
me if i'm not doing everything in my
power to
help to change the things that i don't
like in the world and i think by
focusing on my own impact and by
focusing on the things that i can do
it's a much more positive
narrative than trying to focus on all
the things that aren't right um
i think educating yourself on all the
problems is still really important but
knowing that in your day-to-day actions
you're you're helping to um create a
solution is really good but like i
mentioned before like when i graduated
there were two career paths for somebody
interested in sustainability i guess
also you could become a naturalist um
or like a scientist
but even those jobs were were really
hard to get and very competitive and you
had to go to upper schools also very
expensive
but now like you can fling your arm and
hit like 10 see sustainable companies
like in the face which is really awesome
so that's hope hope in that you know
mainstream media is now talking about
sustainability regularly um
in that like people that don't look like
they'd care at all about sustainability
because of the the preconceived
narratives around what a person
interested in sustainability should look
like come up to me and say i love your
work or i love what you're doing i'm
interested in zero waster i've gone zero
waste like i had a businessman come up
to me yesterday that looked like he had
never even like stepped outside and the
fact that he says i don't like trash now
like that is hope and it's in the little
things but the
the tide is changing people are becoming
more aware of their actions and i think
especially in this political climate
taking responsibility um for their own
actions and for their communities
because they know that nobody else is
going to do it for them and that's why i
see so much hope
yeah i like i would kind of just echo
what lauren said and i think um
i think the fact that we live in a world
where people with a voice can kind of
have their voice out there they don't
need to like you know we're really lucky
to be doing something like this but
people can just get on their social
media and kind of express their opinions
and um there's people like lauren who
you know have like a big following and
can really
kind of preach their message to like a
lot of people at once i think that's a
really important tool and something that
um
that can be used for good and bad you
know but uh luckily a lot of people
really are using it for good
and and i'm encouraged too just by
this feels weird to say but i'm
encouraged
kind of by the way that some things in
politics are going i think kind of with
the current political climate people
have seen
um
kind of how big of an impact that can
have like electing the right politicians
is actually a really important thing and
you know electing the wrong ones can
lead to a lot of huge problems and
things that are really scary and i think
that's inspiring people to kind of
a you know be personally responsible for
their conduct and be to like vote for
politicians that that do care about the
planet and do care about what we're
doing and it's good to see some of those
politicians kind of getting pushed
further away from that kind of middle of
the road like
things like let's just keep going along
this path
and really realizing that you know
drastic action needs to be taken so
that's that's like a big thing for me is
just um
it's kind of people understanding that
that our legislators and our
corporations need to take responsibility
for their actions as well and i do think
people are really pushing them to do
that whether it's through their choices
and kind of like making them realize
there is a market in sustainability
there is a market in conservation or
just through you know electing people
that are going to really kind of put the
pins to them
yeah well thank you guys both for
joining me today uh i i think if anyone
is just like me who needs
more of that daily dose of motivation to
help get over the hump of
wanting to do to actually doing
following both of you guys on social
media as you mentioned is is definitely
uh a way to get that uh so trash is for
tossers uh and a great kid and
package-free and grizz kid um i'm so
good i think that's great uh and if you
enjoyed this conversation about the
great big planet uh and want to see even
more stories about the people who are
who are joining that fight definitely
check out greatbigstory.com
thanks so much
[Music]